hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast investigating
consciousness with closely neural
reinforcement presented by Aurelio
Cortez
he is a researcher at advanced
telecommunications Research Institute
international I am Marjorie Torres of
laggards and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
believe this educational web seminar
presented by labrys labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer with educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many questions is real
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen or use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Aurelio
courtesy I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You Lars
and today I will talk about some recent
experiments that we have been working on
investigating some of the neural
bassists and functions of consciousness
and this we found new and sophisticated
a variety of a stating consciousness
with closing of neural enforcement so
first giving brief production on
consciousness in the brain there are its
there are several debates on that and
after that we go on with talking about
this approach that we've been using
using this multivariate multiversal
approaches to train brain activity and
then I will introduce three different
experiment studies that we've been
running here in Japan let go from let's
say simpler information in the brain
representation and what orientation or
concept or let's say higher order and
abstract representation and finally when
these results that we obtain mean for
our studies of consciousness so for
consciousness in the brain
first of all I think we need to give
let's say to say definition of what is
consciousness and I think there are we
can define this in two different ways
one is simply by accounting for the
levels of consciousness from an example
we have gratefulness or you have a sleep
right for it's our purpose it's actually
more interesting look at consciousness
not in terms of whether there is or not
consciousness in terms of like this
levels on what consciousness means in
the brain and for important if a person
is conscious if you have a conscious
percept this one of the of the theories
would say that to these accounts to have
a global availability of information and
the jurors have self monitoring
processes therefore we can we can see
several aspects of consciousness and of
conscious percent obviously perceptual
awareness would mean when it's related
to our perception while in terms of an
actual single unique concept conscious
or result again self-awareness which is
so obviously the consciousness oneself
and what we are at what time what we do
and if we look then at the literature
there are several different approaches
to data that to look at
just less basically and in terms of
direction that the brain there's also
controversy obviously there are several
researchers that have highlighted
possible new traits in different brain
areas and there's go from the visual
areas to the parietal is of the brain
the frontal areas and even in the deeper
brain nuclei but so given all the
different ideas and approaches and
theories in the standards of
consciousness I think one of the of the
areas that that is very likely to be
involved at least from our point of view
is the prefrontal cortex and there are
several reasons for that term here I
just I'm just giving some of the of the
possible literature that also highlights
the the possible verbal from the cortex
in conscious perception but the idea is
that the prefrontal cortices are
involved in high order thoughts in the
eye or the representation nevertheless
there are several researchers and
studies that also seem to say it to
point to the that before the coating
self is not an accessory for
consciousness but rather it's an area
that is simply involved in the fact that
as humans we are reporting our conscious
experiences but for the actual stop
substrates of a conscious experience a
single conscious person before the
course is not need it and in our view
before my cortex is necessary and a way
to look at that is to think of
confidence so when we want to mean
decisions or when we are basically when
we have a perceptual experiences usually
this is also paired with this certain
confidence our feeling feeling of
certainty and the SDI is that this
reflects consciousness because if we are
conscious of something then we also like
it so let's say we have seen it and
we will also have this feeling of
certainty that you have seen something
on the other end when me if I think no I
have seen that that bad here in the
center or the dog but I'm not sure
because we made school smaller maybe the
image is noise here and because of that
we see this link between confidence and
consciousness and if I go forward and
define I give let's see a definition of
confidence looking to finish maybe we
can actually use in experiments and I
would say that the confidence is the
certainty that my decision was correct
and this actually can also raise the
question is then confidence of the
probability of being correct because
normally if we think of even if our a
simple task in which one has to make
choices usually we have that the
accuracy in the task and the confidence
are very much correlated it's actually
it's difficult to dissociate this and
continue in this we have obviously there
are several ok so there are there there
has been several published picks they
have shown that that actually you have
even the same neural substrates that
encode the decision but also the
confidence and one of this example this
2009 science paper by Rubicon in
Charlaine where they show where they
showed that there were neurons in the
bridle cortex that recording with the
confidence and the decision and even
this then it seems ok well then do i
actually the same neuron same coat these
two different behavioral variables so
then perhaps we'll actually don't need
to even think of the prefrontal cortex
nevertheless when we especially when we
when we study a confidence in humans
then the picture is is quite different
and one of this example is this a paper
in 2010 showed that applying trance
transfer magnetic stimulation to
prefrontal cortex really degraded
confidence ratings is nowadays readings
there were not any more diagnostic
of accuracy in the task but they were a
bit more random and there are also there
are actually other studies that have
shown that it's possible to associate
this accuracy and the confidence because
of these days gives I can offer two
different ways to different hypothesis
in how confidence is actually computed
by the brains the first one is the
normative policies that is I would say
in defining this confidence that
directly reflects sensory appetites and
because of this we would have the same
neural substrates that encodes
confidence and perceptual evidence as it
has already been shown the trusted view
then we have the same your on a
substrate that encodes confidence and
the perceptual evidence and the choices
on the other hand if we think of a
metacognitive hypothesis then confidence
is it is obviously related to the
perceptual evidence and of choices but
is dissociated from it because it's a
late-stage
estimation and therefore given these two
hypotheses to these two views if we
apply for example NASA better wisdom can
disrupt the processing in in in the
specific here when it is applied then
these two hypotheses should live should
lead to two different predictions and
we'd argue also that TMS in a way is a
very coarse manipulation or disruption
because somehow actually it could just
basically increase the noise in the
system and so our idea was let's use a
more sophisticated approach so that we
can actually manipulate for example
confidence with irrationally and really
see if you two can be dissociated
functionally so to do this were what I
would call a sophisticated closed multi
voxel training is an fMRI based approach
that is that when you think of
representations computations and the
link between brain and behavior and cut
the brain there were several ways to to
try to understand this in the brain and
one of them is by using a functional
magnetic resonance imaging fMRI in short
where we can estimate signal changes in
the brain but not directly so doesn't
directly measure the neural activity but
as a surrogate for it
measure the oxygen level not and then
this blood flow and this oxygen level
dependency change changes based on the
on the task and another areas of the
brain involved but now in the past the
way of looking at this this fri data was
simply in a unified way so you just do
like some general statistics in a given
area but in the last let's say 10 years
so this is a start already before but in
the last 10 years there have been really
very big growth in the use of this
multivariate approaches where instead of
just using some summary statistics one
actually tries to make use of all the
information within a certain number of
boxes so boxes is a is a unit of this
like a pixel into the muscle in size we
see in treating in your heavier that for
this multivariate approaches one looks
also at the relationship between the
different boxes of these different
activities and try to make fusions of
these correlations between this
so then provisionally the one can get
out of it is much richer so the way we
apply this is to some standard fMRI
pre-processing but then we use for each
single voxel that you are interested in
the brain we are extract like some time
course and then we apply this machine
learning technique so in our case we
used what we call sparse logistic
regression is a it's relatively standard
and simple machine learning approaches
but which has a strong assumption in
these cases the assumption is about
sparseness which means that within a
given area we assume that most of the
voxels are actually irrelevant for the
task or for the variable of interest
this actually allows
Indian to have much finer
Ellucian so the actual that I would call
this clothes new neural reinforcement it
is a fairly simple process let's say we
have a participant in the scanner we
have a template decoder a template
activation pattern they know in a given
area for example the prefrontal cortex
so what we do is that we ask
participants in the scanner to just try
to manipulate the material productivity
when this scene is Q at induction time
but what we do as experimenter is that
true with our decoder we only do this
online decoding of this build activity
and so essentially this would very
simple terms would account to somehow
compare two different activation
patterns and give a feedback score is a
score that the current activation
pattern is as close as possible to the
target so if it's very close this
feedback this would be large if it's
actually different this feedback circuit
will be smaller importantly there's two
two aspects of it and the first one is
that participants receive a monetary
reward based on the side of duties so
they are motivated to from well and the
second aspect is that they are not aware
of the of the goal of this training so
we don't tell them what is it they are
trying to induce in the pan we just tell
them that they should try to manipulate
the relative as I was saying this we
call this decoder in your field right
because we have a decoder machine
learning classifier and it's a new
feedback paradigms relation Swizzle
neural activity and we feedback this
neural activity in real-time to
participants and I say this essentially
accounts to comparing three different
activation patterns the current one and
a target one and if this then one can
measure if we do because we use very
activity we can we can simply do a
behavioral task for example before and
for the training receive this sense that
tiny changes in behavior for example you
know we're dependent
so as I was mentioning at the beginning
we we did several studies using this
they could in your feedback and this was
rendering from simpler approaches let's
say from simple loop is working on
simple representations from creating
orientation to more I order an abstract
representation in this first study here
the idea was that we had participant
come for two initially for two days the
first day was to do a written notice can
I can this essentially is being in the
scanner we see some very simple basic
visual stimuli that are tuned so that we
can clearly define the different visual
areas in our occipital cortex and then
this case because in this case we were
interested at this orientation and these
are let's say lower lower level features
and therefore I easily found all the
information about this orientation is
easily found the visual cortices then
participant came for what we call this
MVP a session which stands for motor
pattern analysis session so doing this
session but this one will just do a very
simple task in which they have to pay
attention to some stimuli but is that
you use it to have the fMRI signal that
we can use for our decoding for a
classifier so the aim of this of this
study here was to reduce fear responses
to saw more threat signal but to do this
unconsciously so to do this below the
level of consciousness and to do that
participants came and aside from the
first two days of written Auto P and the
critical fraction they were they were
then subjected to to this training were
first during acquisition time they were
thrown different stimuli from which
sometimes some of them were paired with
electric shocks so now they became
conditioned to have a few response to
this
today's a visual stimuli than the other
when this neural reinforcement training
and finally we at the end another DEATH
session to see whether the target
condition stimulus was still fearful or
not and in terms of the actual visual
symmetry used we used as a
different-colored rating and in this
case we are decoded the car it was a red
or green the idea was that one of these
stimuli was the target conditioned
stimulus and the other one was the
control so both of them are become
fearful because they are during this
position time they are paired with a
with a electric shock but only one of
these will be actually a the brain will
be trained to lose this fear this
induction and let's say online training
neural enforcement training the visual
stings was only about their orientation
suppose I was a chromatic and most
vertical orientation there's no
information we would be the target or
the control stimulus then what we saw is
that if we compare the fear responses so
the fear response in this case we use
two different measures one of them the
scheme Paxton's that is how how much the
skin can produce electricity and there
is usually because one is fearful we we
sweat a little bit on our skin and
therefore them the skin from vaccines
becomes here and so what we show here is
that during at the end of the cretaceous
period so before the training was the
target and the control condition seemed
like i have the same level of associated
fear this scr measure is exactly the
same but nevertheless if you look at the
end of this a flutist neural training
now we see that this scr measure as
decreases significantly lower for the
only for the target
distal stimulus this actually clearly
states that only the target which
basically brain activation for this
training had an effect as a
physiological effect not for the control
which was had been untrained and a
second way to look at this that is a few
logical few responses to look at the
atomic and this because the amygdala
generally is the is the brain single
brain region which is mostly associated
with with fear responses and we see the
same pattern X actually and we see that
at the end of the other acquisition we
have the same level of Migdal activity
for both the targets and the control
condition Seema so both of them when
they are shown on the screen a
participant has its any fear response
but again at the end of the of this
reinforcement our training now we see
that for the only four end this only for
a target cognition stimulus we have a
reduction of this mental activity and
this goes to say that we have now two
measures of basically fear reduction and
there is the neural reinforcement
training had this strong physiological
effect but it was a very interesting
point is that participant said at no
time awareness of the target condition
stimulus the colored rating during the
training so this information about this
about the conditions team was present
during the neural enforcement because we
were measuring this brain activity in
real-time and whenever the this target
condition stimulus activation pattern
was present a reward was given but when
we asked participants at the end of the
of the experiment whether which one was
the condition of the control or the
target condition stimulus they were a
chance at the good methods regarding
which group they were so it really had
no awareness at all about this team was
itself I said okay this was just because
this so we have this
representations but these are low-level
it's let's orientational color
individual area so perhaps if we grab it
in higher-order regions and we do the
same kind of training then the rest
participants at one point may become
conscious about it because perhaps if
the representation of the information is
something a little bit more conceptual
or high order then maybe it's perhaps
it's enough to reach consciousness and
to that end we need a second study also
in a way also to to replicate the
previous one and this time it was about
reinforce in conceptual representations
the bridge was slightly different in
that we we also wanted to test whether
it was possible to do this kind of
training by taking let's say go one step
forward and take a brain activation
pattern from subject one and translate
this activation pattern into the brain
coordinate so subject then do the
training in subject to this activation
pattern this is sounds crazy but that's
been developed already a few years ago
by James Haxby and colleagues at
Dartmouth and essentially what
participants do in the scanner the in in
our case they were doing a n-back task
in which the idea it's a very simple
task they are shown different images
that each each one belonging to a
specific category and this very simple
you just have to press a button whenever
the category changes so here in this
example you can see that we have three
images of snake and then suddenly the
next images is a butterfly so the first
butterfly image comes to the the screen
participants have to eat notice change
and so in this experiment they saw 14
categories that were belonging to either
objects or animals and we had several
participants in the end there were at
least 29 that were used as surrogate
participants to to find activation the
target activation pattern in the
designated participant for for the
actual training so this kind of a person
can be so obviously for each which
participants that that comes through
experiment can be a surrogate for all
the others and can be designated for
itself that is that we take we can take
the activation patterns and we use in
this case the venture looking for us as
this as it's an area known for
representing is a categorical conceptual
representation of objects or animals and
this is an iterative process where we
take an activation patterns to run
participants and we try to bring them
all together to a common hyperspace and
doing this by a simple linear
transformation there is that we just
trying to find the perfect the best
combination in terms of a vector of more
boxes so that we have the same category
where the maximum predictive accuracy
because we do this transformation from
the native space of a given participant
in the common space app we can basically
then it becomes easy to to apply in
either direction on this transformation
so but now we can we have this will this
common space we can take a new pattern
from a surrogate participant it's from
his native space to his common abstract
space and then we can applying the
transformation matrix of our target of
our DC participant we can obtain the
target pattern designated at this moment
in the common space this is a general
pattern that is general for all the
participants that for the designated one
is a unique is a unique pattern that is
represented in its own brain context and
so for this we
beginning in this case we also try to
reduce your response to come an object
again unconsciously so I wanted to see
even if we use high order representation
can this still be unconscious and if it
is unconscious then again this could be
an extremely powerful approach to lead
to combine for interventions to reduce
fear in for example in Formica where
difference in pain for big patients the
idea for the for the experiment itself
was was the same as the previous study
in which we have several data of both
new reinforcement training but before
and after that we also do a basically we
also record the fear responses to miss
two different categories and see how
there's if there is a logical feeling of
change after this very important so our
target is we would like to see a
reduction in the fear responses both in
terms of this skin conductance response
and amygdala activity only for the
target I could take away so I actually
forgot but I should mention that the
different categories that were used for
the area for this training there was
always one control and one target object
and the others were before starting this
parent participants rating each one of
these animals and outreach in terms of
how fearful they were and for each one
we selected the two most fearful of it
or or any one and the computer itself
decided which one was the control and
which one was the target for fear to be
reduced so this blend becomes a
completely that will double blind
placebo controlled experiments because
neither the the participant nor the
experiments and knows which one is the
target and which one is the controller
in this case the the numeron force
in training this was exactly exactly the
same way as for the previous study but
his participants tried to induce
activation pattern in the brain we use
our decoder where we can compare the
different activation factors the current
one and the target one and then we can
give a feedback score but I can to some
monetary reward I mean these two what we
see we see that there is a strong
decrease in the physiological fear
response that follows this new
reinforcement so here you have a wide
arsenal before and after for the target
condition and you see that there is a
significant decrease in the industry's
logical response but this is not the
case for the control condition the cases
the intervention was specific for the
target fearful condition and so again
here we have that we have strong
physiological effect but no awareness of
the identity of the target category so
again we ask participants at the end of
the experiment which one they thought
was the target and which one that
supposed to control a degree level were
a chance so they had no insight into
this information was let's see
repeatedly present in their own trainer
so yet now it seems that we went a bit
higher up in terms of representation in
the brain but still participants are are
completely unconscious about the about
Desa the thing that we need something
else maybe something I perhaps we could
think of something even high order
instead of just concept now and this was
a war it's the third experimental
percent here and now it's an abstract
representations because confidence
confidence reporting in a ways so it's
obviously based on some certainty
measure that can also be represented by
yeah by new rooms themselves but overall
confidence our sense of certainty never
decision and so on this is something
that is we can say is quite abstract and
high level higher order in terms of
brain regions as well essentially the
task exam
the structure was similar to the
previous one in that we also wanted to
have two functionally define the visual
areas within which not a P it scan and
we then had participants do again would
recall this maxi box impact analysis
session so during this session
participants were doing a simple
perceptual decision-making task they
were presented with random but emotion
the don't point he was integrated by the
stimulus small slide some of the dots
were moving to the right or left
importantly the percentage of dots with
a coherent Direction was very small so
that the task was difficult by design
but these ones were asked to make this
perception decision by the writer
laughed and then render confidence from
one two four four seven for certainty
and one for there were when they were
like really guessing and completely
uncertain about their choice so again
here confidence is the confidence about
the decision it is how certain how sure
you are that your choice was correct and
we did our analysis or decoding analysis
in several brain areas and those that we
thought were the most relevant for for
confidence based on on the literature
and in previous studies also by our
group there were three sub regions of
the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex and
the inferior parietal but we were also
interested individual areas because here
we're talking about visual perception
and because if confidence in the
accuracy and the decision itself are
very tightly correlated and following
some of the of the parties in the field
may actually be echoed by the same brain
region the neurons and neural circuitry
then perhaps we can actually decode
confidence right in the lower visual
areas what we see in terms of results is
at least in terms of brain regions is a
dissociation in terms of the confidence
so if we try to decode to classify high
versus low confidence based on brain
activity
patterns we see that this can be cannot
be done above chance individual areas
but can be done much of all chance in
front of varietal areas so now we have
signals in the brain in this more high
order frontal regions prefrontal regions
that can classify confidence but cannot
individual areas never at the moment
this doesn't done doesn't tell us
anything on whether conscious confidence
is encoded in our it's in a separate way
and and by by different neural substrate
then there's two other behavioral
variables so the perception and try the
task and the trial you were correct to
incorrect so obviously if this are
encoded by the same neural substrates if
we apply this neuron feedback your
reinforcement approach on confidence but
if these are linked together then we can
will be will actually behaviorally will
provoke changes what is probably most in
confidence but also in the accuracy of
the task induce bias in on left or right
responses but for the actual training we
had some of the participants in total 10
come back to do this counterbalanced to
to block and training which participant
in two different training once for high
in ones for low confidence and please we
can't rewind so that's why we have two
different groups and on each day so on
each block they did first a pretest so
this is the same behavioral task that I
showed you earlier for the construction
of the color itself and the post-test as
well so now we can compare before and
after training how confident so our to
be the behavioral measures changed and
what we and what we had them is that to
their to wait one week and then we had
them come back again to do the opposite
training essentially these accounts to
reinforce it the occurrence of course
activation patterns so
during the actual training we used as
four different brain regions with four
different decoders and the task here for
in terms of the participants was
identical as the fuse studies a show too
so that during the induction time
participants were just focusing and
track into margin changeable activity in
order to maximize some feedback score
but in terms of experimenter his
feedback score was computed based on on
the path code of this 40 colors and then
average give this feedback score and as
I was getting earlier the larger the
disk size the larger the feedback size
the larger the original world that the
participant gets at the end of the
experiment and this silo did increase
maximally when the likelihood of the
target activation pattern was maximum
and this both in the case of low and
high confidence ratings in both cases
the goal of the Pentiums of the
participant here was to maximize the
size of this disc and so what do we see
in this pre and post test so let's have
a look at that so we see that we have
been directional confident changes now
we have that when participants trained
on the on inducing high confidence
patterns now they became more confident
in doing that is a perception task but
they became less confident when they
trained in in the low confidence
feedback no this is a specific result
and this is interesting because now we
see that there is no effect whatsoever
on the task accuracy so the level before
and after this neural training this
completely unchanged in terms of the
accuracy and this is an interesting
point because now we have we have a
dissociation between the two as has been
already shown in the past but now this
dissociation was done at the somehow the
neuron level and I am showing you the
correlation between the ability of
inducing a target I keep pattern so the
more you go to the right side the higher
the likelihood of high confidence
induction the moving into the left side
the lower I conference but the higher
the no confidence induction any
incidents very one was the actual
confident changes
so some of these results here for this
confidence training they give strong
support for this metacognitive APIs the
confidence is Alleyne stage estimation
there is confidence
we have manipulated confidence
representation in the brain in the
prefrontal cortex and then these are
somehow different from the recording of
the perceptual evidence and now after of
the decision itself but not only
different in terms of the behavior of
the behaviors these are obviously are
but in terms of the neural substrates so
we have a different circuitry that it is
basically computing this different
forrester and given these results it
would seem that at least for this kind
of task and this kind of approach the
normative a hypothesis is not really
possible because if it were the case
then if we change in confidence then we
should also see a an effect on the
sensory evidence we should trigger
changes in the perceptual accuracy in
the task and perhaps on some biases but
the interesting thing is that - again we
have strong behavioral effect but again
we have no awareness of this activation
pattern content during the neural
enforcement so when people were we're
trying to manipulate or change their
brain activity so we didn't tell them
what was the purpose of the goal of that
part but they had no awareness of the
activation pattern whether it was a low
or high confidence and we asked them
again at the end of the other training
which order they did first and they
don't know their chance so it seems that
when we take all this data all these
results together from all the several
approaches when we trained the brain to
induce neural activity in several
different areas several different let's
say the order of how do you see let's
say conceptual knowledge from very
simple color orientation to high order
confidence so this should mean something
in terms of the studies of consciousness
and I think it's the main question
actually we can ask you is that the game
to go back to the two main theories of
conscious
is localized focal activity enough give
rise to a conscious percept or we need
something reorient more than that we
need perhaps some generalized Network
activation so we need activities spread
over several brain areas and you need
connectivity or let's say cross talking
between different naps and different gas
perhaps also need due to these rules I
need to have some I or the
representation of the of the lower one
ladies we need so we have a lower or the
representation of exit of an object of a
concept but we need to have higher-order
presentation of that and this branch is
only available if there is a generalized
activation and indeed so what I would
argue is that prefrontal cortex is
needed for the for consciousness as a
neural basis of consciousness obviously
we would the data the results I showed
you here we cannot directly tell this
because in all different studies there
was actually no conscious percept about
the information present in the brain at
those specific time points from the
neural training but because of the
especially of the lab targeting
confidence we see that confidence is
encoded in the prefrontal cortex and
evidence we can directly relate it to
the conscious experience system we could
say that it is likely that confidence
and consciousness share also the same
neural substrate that is the prefrontal
cortex to go back to these two different
views of localized focal activity which
I could we could call look and the
current processing that is this is
posits that we are you its to have a
conscious perception need activation and
localized
when they find reason while if we think
of this global broadcasting which is
another aspect of of the consciousness
then a theory of consciousness then here
we need this is connectivity's and large
activation patterns across several
layers of the brain then I would say
that consciousness
it's probably missing it's probably
arising from these global activation but
it also strongly reflects this a
self-monitoring and they would give the
link with with confidence itself that is
consciousness can be seen as as made of
several aspects one of them is the
self-monitoring of which this confidence
judgment this confidence feeling that we
have the certainty feeling is a direct
reflection and so with that I would like
to thank and acknowledge my
collaborators both here in in Japan
especially kobato and i could sue me i
was the first author of the of the first
studies introduced then i would like
also to thank hackman now and Vasa -
with Michele he was the first author of
the second study about reducing fears
for common objects and no need to thank
us under our funding agency you for your
attention and I think now we can open
questions thank you dr. Aurelio Cortez
for that informative presentation we
will now start to lie to you and I
portion Octomom if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do something
just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation the window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is what were
participant strategies during the neural
reinforcement sessions thank you for the
question so interestingly all
participants reported wildly different
strategies during this day's
reinforcement sessions there is they
never reported things that were related
to black
tasks in question I think there were
only two occasions among all the
subjects for the three different studies
and those two were in the study
regarding the conceptual representation
of objects to reduce fear for objects in
which if I'm not wrong there were two
participants that somehow at some points
thought about one of the two categories
but they never knew which one was the
target which one was the control in all
the other study strategies were ranging
from I was thinking about my lunch I was
focusing on something I have to do
sports some training and I'm thinking
that I'm doing mental calculations so
strategies were very different but never
involve the actual task thank you for
that answer our next question is and the
second study will be responses to common
objects for reduce the participants fear
ratings also change or was effect purely
physiological there is a very
interesting question because we see
there's strong physiological responses
that is with fear that is been used
specifically for the target stimulus in
the images for the target object but
interestingly when participants were
asked to rate their it's a fear or how
fearful where all the different
categories the target under control
were rated equally as before the
training so there was no change in that
sense now there could be several reasons
for that but an interesting one an
interesting interpretation is that these
newer reinforcement training really are
below the consciousness level that is we
play with these representations we
reinforced them this has a strong impact
on the low lab and processing
there's a in the fear circuitry but does
not reach consciousness now if you want
to apply this for actual treatment of
phobias for example then it could be
actually a very interesting approach
because one could could think of using
first this new enforcement according
your feedback technique initially to
decrease this is a kind of condition or
physiological responses and then once
this are lower or more less amenable
then perhaps it should become easier to
combine this with some cognitive therapy
because one of the issues with those
kind of treatments and say cognitive or
with exposure therapy
is that there's a there is a certain
level of dropout that is it's it's too
too fearful to just look repeated in
today's images but now if you are if
your brain has learned not to be at
least implicitly fearful foolish then
perhaps it could become easier to have
this also the conscious level afterwards
thank you for that answer
our next question is regarding the study
on confidence could the changes be
accounted for by changes in mood or
other unspecific effects interesting
question in the illness so we see there
is a changes in confidence and if those
were purely changes of confidence then
we one way to actually prove this and I
didn't sure I didn't show it here in the
in my talk for the sake of time but one
of the analysis we did afterwards was to
look at method II prime so meta D prime
is a index of meta cognitive ability it
is not only assesses how confident you
are but it tracks it with no I basically
it tracks how confidence and and the
accuracy in the tasks are linked on a
trial
trial basis so normally if one is is a
as a high metacognitive a sensitivity or
ability then you have a very strong
relationship between let's see correct
choices and high confidence and
incorrect choices and no confidence now
if so if the change in confidence is
just due to some form of let's say bias
in the report or some mood effect then
you just expect to have a general shift
or let's say higher or lower confidence
right and if that were the case we
should not really see a change in this
method D prime because now it would be
it would just be really a shift that's a
criterion shift and what you do see is
that at least for the high confidence
training we see a significant reduction
in the meta D prime for the lower
confidence we don't see that there could
be several reasons one of them is
perhaps because overall it difficult to
decrease a let's say a function or
representation there is in this case
confidence rather than increase it
another interpretation is that the task
itself is already difficult it's already
ambiguous so confidence is generally
speaking already relatively low it's
much easier to increase and decrease
okay we'd have time for one more
question our last question is given
these results and adding to previous
research it seems local representations
are not sufficient to create
consciousness you think it may be
possible to utilize decoded in Europe it
feedback to induce a conscious person
accident I think you've got the point of
that we haven't managed yet to forget to
let us say creating a conscious percept
now with with with this neural feedback
these neural training approaches that
we've been using so far as I was
mentioning during the talk these were
always about localized some are
localized representation and this way
was not
to create cultures but what we think is
that if we can use this this technique
ISM not only to induce or to reinforce
localized activity but also let's say
some some pattern of kind of functional
information transmission or some form of
information flow from between different
areas as as it is basically opposed in
this global availability of global work
space a theory then perhaps we could get
at that point to be able to actually use
some conscious percept
we are working toward that direction and
we are devising several studies some of
them are already being on the work so I
think stay tuned and maybe some not so
distant future
we may be able to do that I would like
to once again thank dr. aurelia courtesy
for his presentation I would also like
to thank laberd's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June F 2018
you'll receive an email from Lavery's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye